with us now Democratic strategist Kevin
Walling and tag strategies VP Aaron
perini thank you both for joining us
here I want to add kind of what Kevin
was saying they're a little bit more
context I like to put this up on the
screen this is migrant encounters fiscal
year 2022
2.15 million on Pace for 2.3 million by
the way and since Biden took office
you've got 3.59 Million by any
definition Aaron this is a crisis a
disaster at the border and the vice
president who's in charge of that goes
to Texas and fails to go to the Border
what do you think
well it's a repeated pattern of behavior
from this Administration from vice
president Kamala Harrison from Democrats
as a whole we are she goes to Texas
again for the second time as vice
president and doesn't go fully to the
Border because she doesn't want to
acknowledge and actually see the crisis
that her and Joe Biden's policies have
perpetrated against the American people
against States like Texas Nevada and
Arizona you see the Rio Grande Valley it
is being absolutely overrun and
Democrats strategy right now is really
bewildering to me because it seems to be
put your head in the sand Democrats
don't want to talk about the Border
crisis and you have the Democrat
Congressional Campaign committee
chairman over in Paris fundraising
Democrats are doing everything except
acknowledging the realities the
disasters their policies have Unleashed
on the American people all across the
country yeah and it's a fair point Kevin
because you know the Democrats don't
want to talk about it the left media
doesn't want to talk about it
representative Tony Gonzalez in Texas he
wants to talk about it here's what he
said watch he doesn't have to visit me
I'm a republican I get that but guess
what Henry Cuellar is a Democrat Vicente
Gonzalez is a Democrat uh Veronica
Escobar is a Democrat she could visit
anywhere along the border the fact is
they've put their head in the sand
they've abandoned they've abandoned us
along the border and Democratic members
of Congress Kevin are not happy about
her not visiting the Border
well certainly to Aaron's point it is a
crisis and and I'm a Democrat on your
panel that is willing to admit that but
look at what the administration has been
doing year over year we've been surging
resources in the fiscal budget for more
Patrol officers on that border more
Security in terms of building more
physical walls more surveillance across
that border where there are different
terrains that can be secure but listen
this is certainly a serious issue you
point out those numbers and they are
horrifying when you see the number of
people coming across I think that's a
direct result of a lot of the violence
that they're fleeing a lot of the the
hunger and famine that people are
fleeing a lot of the crime in these
Northern triangle countries that people
are fleeing coming out of covid and the
desperation to cross a desert with your
children over days long Journeys to get
to the United States we've got to do
more when it comes to not just securing
the Border but passing comprehensive
immigration reform that's going to to
finally tackle this issue yeah I just
want to move on now if I can to the
midterms because there's a huge Senate
race going on in Ohio there was a debate
tonight between JD Vance and Tim Ryan
here's what they said watch oh by the
way that's the race 46.2 uh JD Vance is
a little bit of a lead there still
within the margin of error and here's a
little bit from the debate watch
if you get raped
JD Vance and others are going to say you
have to have that baby State mandated
pregnancies for a rape victim that is so
far out of the mainstream it's not even
funny that poor girl was raped by an
illegal alien somebody that should have
never been in this state in the first
place you voted so many times against
border wall funding so many times for
amnesty Tim if you had done your job she
would have never been raped in the first
place
yeah you can see Aaron they're talking
about two of the top issues right you're
talking about abortion and you're
talking about the Border uh your
thoughts on how that race is shaping up
I would expect to see JD Vance to start
to take a further lead away from Tim
Ryan for a number of reasons this debate
I have to really applaud JD Vance he
prepped hard and he showed up time and
again he did not allow Tim Ryan to try
and Define his positions he talked about
the fact that he believes in reasonable
exceptions and in the case of that
ten-year-old he said that he would have
said that that was an abortion that
should have been allowed and that child
should not have had to cross sides but
he brought it back to a much stronger
point and Tim Ryan had no excuse for his
20 years of failure there's a lot of
money coming into Ohio in this race you
should expect to hear about the economy
crime immigration China things that are
really affecting Ohioans in a way that
JD Vance is relating with them Tim Ryan
came off as out of touch and
unpersonable and I think you will
continue to see JD Vance to take more of
a sizable lead in this race it's going
to be close Kevin I mean that's the
bottom line here it's within the margin
of error it is going to be closed so
nobody doubts that it could be pivotal
your final thoughts
yeah Teresa I'm right there with you I
couldn't disagree with my dear friend
Aaron Moore I thought I thought Tim Ryan
had a great debate he was personal he
took the fight to JD Vance over his
extreme views especially with regards to
abortion pointing out that rape to JD
Vance is just an inconvenience that
speaks volumes to women in the Buckeye
state and it's certainly going to be
close race it's about a 1.2 percent race
right now according to Real Clear
Politics it's going to be a dog fight
they've got one more debate before uh
election day and I can't wait to watch
that one too yeah I know you liked uh
you you liked the Democrat in these
races you also said Blake Masters did
very well I mean you did Bart Kelly did
very well against like Masters last week
in Arizona and a lot of people beg to
differ on that one Kevin Kevin Aaron
great to see you both I love it Trace
thank you there I appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most telling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else